hello would welcome to video playing
bones Grand Master Fung quotes go ahead
and played him for a while since it's
been maybe a little bit less active or I
don't know i mean i didn't i didn't
remember I don't remember that we played
games and the recent in recent times
okay um I don't really know this line
all that well mmm I wanted to go g6 but
I wondered if Queen d3 ism maybe I can
go to d6 then it looks very weird but is
that something okay so yeah I think I
probably just take and this is a line
that I have to check really i'm
currently just playing it oh that feels
like feels like a very dangerous move
currently I'm just playing it by ear and
regarding I mean it's it's it's a fairly
um tricky tricky thing wow it's is six
or something
if I go if he takes this on a 7 and I
recapture does he have some Queen B 6 or
something like that it looks very shaky
looks very shaky if he goes III or
something okay can I take this I mean 26
I mean okay let threatens on c5 I can
take me to so ants nests that isn't all
that dangerous maybe I can do the same
mmm yeah but is it sets all that
dangerous what is the threat in this
position I don't quite see if there is a
threat I can take be too with what I'm
trying to say I think I'll do that why
can I not take this okay i also have the
check but then well I can do it I can do
this check and if we actually okay if he
moves the king I've night f5 I also have
the simple check here Jackie let's do
the check it's not to be too fancy ok I
think I can play night f5 in this
position I'm reasonably sure I can it
doesn't have a check and Bishop d8 night
takes t6 is just great for black um if
he takes c5 I can take d to NH 4 so then
wins the wind stuff why is it not a 5
working is there draw back to that move
I mean that's Queen d5 but I don't
believe in that that shouldn't be a real
concern ok I won't ever overlooking
something yeah but just it doesn't work
right why does that work
Queen age for have all kinds of things
on the king maybe I'm just too
optimistic but ok I'm going to go for
this anyway and what is no big choice
then ok I can take on d24 Queen default
check this isn't all that bad if I go
Queen d 4 immediately you can take my
Bishop King e7 and he has to play work
the one at the end which is at least a
draw but I don't want to draw here so
I'm going I'm going to Castle here and
just play play this position let's see
here umm i have d 4 as a cool before I
think 494 stuff is going to go III i
guess but still I can take any way I am
I'm just taking too much time I'm taking
too much time like adoring this is the
school position and while I do that I
lose I lose on the clock so he couldn't
take it because of group d aid IDK Loire
Castle him sd2 is hanging
so what is he going to do like rock t 1
maybe something like this attending 94
he takes Bishop g4 which looks pretty
awful 94 is a threat but my time my time
my time okay so maybe just this intended
to capture and play Queen c3 I have to
be quick yeah being so much down
download time so take a five now what's
the deal but I can recapture right k x
takes you cannot take the bishop man
what is he doing here I can take here
right King takes Queen c3 is going to be
a maid or some kind of wind i mean can
do lunch a tragic yeah it will it will
definitely win time money hey and here
24 for bishops III
or Bishop e3 is that better and improved
in Jack so just take it so what's what's
the point after somehow get around to
the a pawn should that doesn't work how
do I get to the aim on to a five or
something 24 seconds I basically have to
win by checkmate but it's not impossible
that this is this might happen
Queen a5 trying to take on a 2 i've been
very slow looking too much at this nice
position and not playing Queen d5 Queen
f2 is so we know that that's made on d 2
I think it's a winning position but
threatening be three maybe find some
defense here melissa is really really
good player so it's possible that I
don't manage in the time
I think I have a draw here at least
which is not really great but check
check check check check I don't know if
I ever win here check I would love to
what I only have a couple of SAC game
drown yeah I mean this is a winner but
to have 10 seconds on the clock so where
is the win actually with Ruby ate at the
end it must be a win but I have 10
seconds so the winners here Jacqueline
this position check check check check
and now we ate attending this yeah okay
give me like 30 seconds then I can do
that but not with no time I mean okay it
was a pretty cool game so g6 he went
here yeah this is kind of interesting i
hack I totally did not see d6 not sure
how bad it is but I absolutely did not
have it on the radar yeah okay I have to
do this and now he went for this Queen
d6 operation I just think it doesn't
work actually yeah engine agree is not
f5 is also great for black the IE I
immediately but why not taking I mean I
their 5s may be cleaner I saw the move
but we should be to just look too
tempting yeah here white um well this I
have Quinn Asia I've actually and then
it will create okay that's interesting
yeah and this this is just brilliant for
black this is hanging at bit we're
saying but ok this just look too
tempting you to not play right at five
yeah this is this is a total mess now of
course it's interesting
shooter wants to when to send even work
others 25 a 10 hour came i will look
something crucial here a computer wants
to take and i would I intended I thought
I could do this and take here and there
is clarity five so this what I wanted to
do didn't work but i will have
alternatives for example here I can play
them um I can take immediately and play
this which is kind of interesting I mean
I have a decent development here okay
but it's not a big advantage or anything
this is why the other line with
immediate 95 probably is to be preferred
okay he plant 25 and this should lose
made a solution it's minus three but
okay you still have to do it them before
you three rookie 895 rpa there okay okay
okay i see you create this threatens to
take on e3 makes it very very strong go
kingdom one and then this is a this is a
killer that's very very cuter if the
night moves there's a maid down and this
is also not helping wow wow now that
would have been the immediate kill but
ok t5 is not a lot of bad move it still
keeps a win see you form no d4 okay I
went through PA but it also wins right
okay and you shouldn't take your form rd
takes it for us more convincing actually
okay mmm the reason is i have III
probably are now now queen deform okay
that's devastating fun evaluation minus
70
okay yeah but ok this this wind is well
right to check I mean I had to have to
be somewhat somewhat quick now yeah
bring the Queen and Queen around I just
ran out of time I'd be three immediately
what's also cool check check but it's
it's I think it's it's basically the
same thing I mean check check the same
winning method I be sure before huh what
is that doing actually this is an idea
okay then the check yeah okay but i just
spent too much time in hitch enjoying
the position okay okay it was a cool
game I think I was nice okay thanks for
watching